[APPLAUSE]
– If you'd like to stand there.
And what's your name?
– Olivia
– Olivia, all right.
So Olivia is going to be the internet
and again Andy and I
going to try to exchange keys,
but this time in the electronic world.
We're going to send
all our information through you
and you're going to try as hard as you can
to steal our secret key.
Alright so keys in the electronic world
are really numbers,
but we're going to represent
numbers by colours.
So each colour represents
a different number.
And we're going to start with
the color blue.
Now blue is not a secret colour,
everybody knows blue.
So I've got some blue,
Andy's got some blue,
and Olivia's got some blue.
The next thing I'm going to do
is I'm going to choose
a secret colour,
and my secret color
is going to be yellow.
Now I can't just send yellow
across the internet to Andy,
because it will be stolen on the way.
So to keep it secret,
what I'm going to do
is to mix it with the blue.
If I mix yellow and blue,
I get green.
And that's another example
of a one-way process.
Just took a few seconds to mix
the yellow and the blue to make green,
but if you had to take the green
and separate all the molecules out,
to get the blue
and the yellow again
it would take millions of years,
it would be very hard.
Okay so I'm going to take this green
and I'm going to send it over the internet,
but remember you're trying
to steal all our secrets.
So what I want you to do
is to make a copy of this colour.
Okay, so what I want you to do
is to pour half of the liquid
into this container.
If you just pour it
up to that line, that's good.
And keep going a bit more...
And I'd stop about there,
that's excellent.
Okay and you can pass the rest
over to Andy.
Now Andy's going
to do something similar,
he's going to dream up
a secret colour,
in his case
the secret color is red.
Again, he can't send the red to me
through the internet
or it will be copied, so he's going to use
this one-way process
he's going to mix it
with the blue.
So he gets a sort of purpley colour.
And now he's going to send that mixture
to me over the internet.
And again, you're trying
to steal our information,
yeah you've got the hang of it,
so you pour half of it
into that container,
just up as far as the line.
A little bit more... bit more...
Excellent thank you very much,
and you give the rest to me.
Okay so here I have a mixture
of red and blue.
What I'm going to do is to
add my secret colour which is yellow.
So I have a mixture
of red, yellow and blue.
Andy's got a mixture of yellow and blue
and he's going to add his
secret colour which is red.
Ao Andy now also has a mixture
of red yellow and blue.
So we've managed to agree
on the same secret colour.
And if we just put these together
in the middle...
I hope you'll be able to see
that those are indeed the same colour.
Alright, what about our internet thief,
what information do you have?
Can you make this same colour?
Let's have a look.
Well this colour
is a mixture of red and blue
and that's definitely
a bit different.
You've got some yellow in here,
mixed with some blue
so you can't unmix the colours,
remember you can only mix things.
So why don't you try adding this to that
and see if you can copy our secret colour.
And what we'll see is that –
that's it just pour it all in, that's good.
Now this is a different
color it's a different color because
this is a mixture of red plus blue,
plus yellow plus blue,
so it's got twice as much
blue in it.
And the only other color you
know about is blue,
so if you pour that in as well...
That's actually just going to
make things even worse,
there's even too much blue now.
You can stop there that's fine.
So we've seen how Andy and I
have been able to agree
on a secret colour,
and in the electronic world
that means we've agreed on a secret number.
So next time you see that little yellow padlock
on your web browser,
you'll know that your computer
and the website computer
have done a little exchange
of secret numbers just like this one.
And that means it's now okay
to put your credit card information
or whatever it is into that website,
because it'll be scrambled
and other people won't be able to read it.
Okay thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]